bethenny starts off this hour in phoenix
hi Bethany welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show what are you thankful for a lot of
things that I have my kids and my
husband a roof over my head and food in
my kitchen so I'm doing well
yeah amen I love it how can I help today
I kind of feel like I'm calling in with
the first world problem now it's all
good I'm having a really big dilemma
about our car situation because I don't
know how to solve it without going to
debt and I really don't want to get more
debt onto our plate I just don't see how
we're gonna do this so we have a vehicle
and we have to have a vehicle that has a
third row we have four young kids we
have to fit in the bag and right now
there's about thirty five hundred
dollars worth of fixes have to do to it
which is more than what it's worth right
now and so we're trying to figure out
you have thirty five hundred dollars
exit no we don't we we've been saving a
thousand dollars about four or five
different times this year and it's just
a year of Murphy's Law
for some reason for us and every time I
get that Alvin dollars I get wiped out
with another emergency so we're back to
saving that thousand dollars again right
now how many kids and so now we're four
and what's your household income
combined is about 88 to 89 thousand
before taxes don't you okay and you have
one car or two we have two cars okay all
right good
and so the the beater with the fourth
with enough room for the four kids is
they're saying it's worth 3,500 but
they're saying there's $3,500 worth of
repairs no they're saying if everything
was fixed it'd be worth $3,500 $3,500
well that's absurd you would you would
never spend $3,500 $3,500 we wouldn't
fix everything what's wrong with it
what's keeping it from running is it
running it's running okay we were at the
point where we
the water pump is leaking which is the
biggest problem and that needs to be
done right away and we were gonna fix
that because that was just under a
thousand dollars but now it just failed
emissions and I can't even rear edge'
stir it I'm actually driving it on an
expired registration right now until we
can get the catalytic converter fixed
which is another thousand dollars and
then the power steering rack and pinion
need to be changed as well well that's
that's always going on a car that's worn
out and that cars one yeah and so that
one I knew we could wait a couple months
on the power steering rack but I would
solve it choreographer
I think the car as yours will probably
bring two or three grand okay because
Kelley Blue Book value telling me like a
thousand dollars it's what we could get
out of it since it's not passing a
mission well I mean I'm not sure Kelley
Blue Book is accurate we're dealing with
a piece of junk like this so I mean it's
a car that's worth anywhere from two to
three thousand dollars you've got the
emissions but there are most people that
put a catalytic converter on that car
are going to do it themselves that is
not all or you take to a mechanic and
spend a thousand dollars on dope-ass
emissions
okay so and that my husband thinks he
might be able to figure out that
called--it comforter himself okay
another thing that we're looking at that
would be okay to and so you know what I
would do if you if he could do that for
a couple of hundred dollars and you can
get this water pump fixed some other way
for the water pump for a thousand dollar
sounds a little rich to me that's a lot
for a water plan and they and they told
us it's because of they basically have
take up almost the whole engine so it's
mostly labor not necessarily a part
because it's the what the way the engine
is fit into the engine compartment it's
a right it's like a fan it's a Honda
Pilot yeah yeah it's a valiant okay all
right well III I'm gonna get another bid
or two and try to try to get this water
pump going and get this catalytic
converter going for a thousand dollars
combined instead of two thousand dollars
combined and then I'm gonna sell it
okay animal sell it for thirty five
hundred bucks and I'm gonna take the $35
and buy a different car for $3,500
because you don't have any money and and
no I'm not gonna tell you going to death
I know you're frustrated I know this is
driving you crazy but you've also got
panic here that's for giving you
ridiculous advice anybody that seriously
suggest how much from two different
quotes so they were pretty similar
anybody that suggest you spend $3,500 on
this car is not giving you sincere
advice okay that's absurd I mean it's
asinine and you knew it right you knew
not to do so you haven't had or not
we're not going to spend that money on a
car that's gonna break down again in
another mile they might all break down
you never know but we're not gonna spend
$3,500 on the 3500 on our car that's
just nuts you know now I'm gonna spend
$2,000 on 3,500 other cars so let's get
her patched up and get her sold because
this one's about you've about run out of
emotional energy with this car but
you're not going to get a whole lot
better car for the same kind of money
with the fourth you know that'll hold
for kids so it's gonna still be a
struggle for now the good news is you
make eighty eight thousand and this is
not a forever issue right but right now
you've just got this piece of junk
hovering in the driveway and you got to
deal with it okay better piece of junk I
didn't save our money in the meantime
and if you want stop your debt snowball
for right now because this is a
household emergency right now and say
well we've got to have an extra thousand
to fix this car and we really need to
pile another thousand up and add with
the sale of this car and move up a tiny
bit in car or save up two thousand and
move up a tiny bit in car and drive it
you know fix it drive it for a month you
know and and that kind of thing and
let's just but real quickly not not you
know not not a six month plan but but
within the next 60 to 90 days let's have
this thing fixed have it get out of here
and move up a little bit but always in
cash do not let this push you back into
car payment land that is not the answer
to your long-term plan it is the answer
to your short term pain and your short
term frustration it absolutely would fix
that having a car payment would fix
that but it's not the answer to your
long-term best interest for your family
so don't don't cave don't let the
pressure push you into doing something
dumb and and you're very close to that
point thanks for the call